so tonight a lot of the women yelling
over each other you were in the hot seat
you guys have been critiqued as being
the most traumatic group ever it was
madness but you know at the end of the
day we all are human and we all went
through this together so I think that is
one thing that we can all come to a
common ground on and appreciate about
each other whether we agree with each
other or not we can all appreciate each
other but you saw Peter tonight and you
got emotional I mean no one was shocked
we love you you are an emotional person
are you still in love with him what were
your feelings for him like tonight I
think I was in love with him but I've
done a lot of soul-searching and re
watching the show reliving the show I
realized that you know my feelings were
real but I've also moved on but I've
also appreciated our relationship and
I've learned a lot from it and all I can
do is you know grow from it okay let's
talk about Kelsey in the crying we love
you you have embraced the crying crying
is cool it's cool how's Shay crying
school well I think it back did you
realize how much you did cry during the
season I don't think it was just me that
was kind of woman she Kelsey it was not
am i emotional
absolutely I'm not gonna deny that do I
cry as much in normal life as they do on
the show no look you had a lot of iconic
moments on the show the crying and
champagne gate Kelsey
[Music]
okay I have to ask you have you drank
champagne since filming or you have okay
you're embracing it I didn't know I
don't know if it was to talk I know I
think in Champagne sent me literally
half my fridge is champagne right now we
have to have you own roses and roses and
drink champagne champagne I love that
so you're a human being who's also
getting some Bachelorette talk are you
in talks to be the Bachelorette and
would you take on the role I own esteem
been talked to about it so I really
haven't been thinking about it when I
came on the show I came on it for one
reason and that was honestly to find
love I didn't expect to fall for Peter
like I did but I did so my end goal was
to be with him but what about Paradise
the heat might be a little too much for
me
Costa Rica was a lie I was half my
makeup sweating off I was like you can
have tequila gate in paradise I don't
think champagne gate well I hope for it
who do you think that Peter ends up with
nobody knows everyone keeps asking me
this and I honestly have no idea who is
barb crying about I don't know I wish I
knew because it's literally driving me
insane all of us and say my last
question for you you and Tammy went
head-to-head tonight and Tammy made a
big accusations she said that you were
drinking too much how do you feel about
that now what kind of place are you guys
in this is the thing when you're on the
show everybody knows the viewers don't
know this but everybody that have been
on the show no you get two drinks an
hour your medication is taken from you
it's handed to you by the doctor you get
five pills a week like everything is
super monitored so I was a little
confused by those accusations and also -
she wasn't one of my friends so for her
to come to me and express his
accusations and want to do it on camera
not off camera because we had the
opportunity to talk about it off camera
was just a little manipulative to me and
that's what didn't sit well with me so
friends not friends
frenemies
[Music]